SANDER BOGDAN: Welcome to
Google Cloud Next 2021.
In today's talk,
Secure and Reliable
Continuous Delivery to
Google Kubernetes Engine.
In today's talk,
we're going to talk
through some of the challenges
of continuous delivery to GKE.
We'll discuss the
principles that
can be applied to
address those challenges.
We'll be introducing
Google Cloud Deploy.
And finally, we'll show a demo.
My name is Sander Bogdan,
and I'm a product manager
with Google Cloud.
And I'm joined today by Bryan
Morgan, who's an engineering
manager with Google Cloud.
So let's start off by
talking about challenges.
Over the past 18 months,
we've had the opportunity
to speak with numerous
Google Cloud customers
about the continuous delivery
challenges they face with GKE.
And from those conversations,
three themes emerge.
The first theme is
cost of ownership.
Defining robust
delivery pipelines,
patching, pooling, and scaling
an organizational continuous
delivery capability can be
both difficult and complex.
And even when an organizational
continuous delivery capability
has been established,
knowing what to measure
and how to optimize those
measurements for success
is often unclear.
But in all situations,
continuous delivery investment
intensity can detract
from core business focus.
So the second theme we observed
was around security and audit.
Controlling releases as
they make their way out
to a production
environment, approving
releases for production, as
well as delivery pipeline access
control and audit were
repeated as fundamentally
necessary to modern
software delivery.
And the final theme
was integrations.
Continuous delivery capability
exists within software delivery
ecosystems.
And because of that,
systems integrations
such as with continuous
integration, connecting
complex workflows such as
multi-step, multi-party
approvals, and advanced
networking requirements
demand continuous delivery
tooling flexibility as well as
modularity.
And these three themes are best
summed up by recent customer
quote, and that quote
went something like this,
"We cannot afford to be
innovating in continuous
delivery.
We want an opinionated
product that provides
best practices out of box."
And while this quote is
associated with one customer,
the reality is it
could be assigned
to any number of customer
conversations that we've had.
All right.
Now that we've talked
about the challenges,
I'd like to talk through
some of the principles that
can be applied to
addressing these challenges.
So there are four.
The first principle is Easy--
make it easy to define
robust delivery pipelines,
to onboard delivery
pipelines, scale them,
and to apply best practices
as part of their setup.
And we believe the best way to
do this is through a managed
opinionated service,
and Bryan's going
to be talking more
about that later.
The second principle is Control.
Continuous delivery
tooling must facilitate
manual and automated
release control
as it makes its way out through
a production environment.
So that includes activities
like promotion, rollback,
as well as approvals.
The third principle is Security.
And what that means is
platform administrators
must have the ability to
restrict delivery pipeline
definition and activities.
They need to be able to
control who is doing what,
where, and when.
And when an audit
is needed, that
should be handily available too.
And the final principle is
about providing insights.
So continuous
delivery capability
must provide insights
both collectively
as well as individually for
delivery pipeline progressions,
activities, and opportunities
to further optimize delivery
stability as well
as release velocity.
So again, the four
principles are
make it easy-- to make
it easy to onboard,
make it easy to
scale, and make it
easy to maintain
continuous delivery tooling
using best practices.
The second is provide control.
Releases should be controllable
as they make their way out
through a production
environment.
The third principle
is security-- control
who can do what, where,
and when with audit.
And finally, provide
insights to further optimize
your continuous
delivery practices.
So now that I've talked
through these principles,
I'd like to hand
it over to Bryan,
who's going to talk to
how Google Cloud applies
these principles.
Bryan?
BRYAN MORGAN: Thanks, Sander.
Continuous delivery
capabilities frequently
exist within a software
development lifecycle
ecosystem.
This implies flexibility and
modularity, as Sander noted,
as a delivery
tooling requirement.
For GCP customers, connecting
Google and third-party tooling
that intersects with
your delivery processes
is a necessity, particularly
when you already
have continuous integration,
approval workflows,
and associated test automation.
We have found that GCP
Kubernetes customers typically
mature in their usage
of GKE over time.
Starting out, customers may
have a single config that
targets a single
cluster, but this usually
grows into multi-config,
multi-cluster usage.
From there, teams often find
that application configuration
should be standardized
and source
code controlled, allowing them
to templatize configuration
changes.
Finally, advanced customers find
tools such as KEP and Kustomize
to be extremely
useful in allowing
them to make increasingly
sophisticated and automated
configuration changes
across environments.
Most software delivery
pipelines can be thought
of as a three-step process--
define, manage, and deliver.
Because usage of
GKE is a journey,
we advocate using Skaffold for
the local development loop.
From there, Skaffold
profiles, in combination
with the managed continuous
delivery service,
can be used to define delivery
pipelines and orchestrate
releases.
Finally, that service
can actuate the release
to GKE target clusters.
Up until this point, we've
discussed the challenges,
principles, and application
of those principles
for continuous
delivery into GKE.
Now, I'd like to step
through the key features
of our recent public preview
launch of Google Cloud
Deploy, GCP's continuous
delivery service for Google
Kubernetes Engine.
We have engineered
Google Cloud Deploy
to be a scalable managed
service that enables
continuous delivery to GKE.
Cloud Deploy relies on
a ConfigOS code model
with declarative manifests
for configuring the delivery
pipelines.
In addition, it performs
GKE manifest rendering
and deployment on your behalf.
Cloud Deploy additionally
supports a number
of security features,
including a discrete IEM
model, direct integration
to GCP Cloud audit logs,
manual approvals as part of
a deployment process flow,
and even execution on
Cloud Build private pools
for customers that desire
security and control
over their environments.
Finally, Cloud Deploy
has integration points
to enable both Google and
third-party delivery-related
tooling and process
integrations.
I'd like to briefly walk
you through the experience
before I go into our demo.
In this first slide, you can
see that Google Cloud Deploy
organizes CD workflows
around pipelines,
which can be
monitored and measured
using the GCP Cloud
console as well
as our gcloud command-line
interface and API.
Next, in the Delivery
Pipeline Details view,
a pipeline's rollouts
can be controlled
through promotions
and approvals, which
are again available
via the Cloud Console
UI and the gcloud CLI.
You'll also note a
delivery pipelines release
history is accessible
for similar review
and taking action.
Users with appropriate
permissions
can then proceed with
a release promotion
to evaluate configuration
changes that
are included with the
release to be deployed.
The Cloud Console user
interface supports
direct visual differentials to
aid in the release progression
decision-making process.
I'd like to now demonstrate
the use of Google Cloud Deploy
to deploy an application to a
series of GKE target clusters.
In this demo, I will
step through the process
of creating a GCP Cloud Deploy
release, deploying to staging,
then approving a
production rollout.
Today, I'm going to demo
the new Cloud Deploy
service from Google.
We'll start with
a GitHub repo that
contains two applications that
will build two containers.
That application is in
this example directory,
and you'll see
there's a container
called leeroy-app and a second
container called leeroy-web.
Both containers include their
own Kubernetes deployment
manifest as well as
a Skaffold config
that defines how
those containers will
be built and deployed.
You can see here
that we're planning
to use the standard kubectl
dplyr to deploy the two GKE
clusters.
If I take a look at GKE
and my Cloud console,
you can see that I've already
pre-created three clusters--
a test, staging, and prod.
So those are already
ready and waiting for me.
So the first step I want to
do is to go into Cloud Shell.
I've already pulled
the repo down.
So I want to do a Skaffold
build and upload-- building
will upload those containers
to Artifact Registry.
All right.
We can see the container
build is finished.
They have been uploaded.
I'm going to go check out
my Artifact Registry just
to verify.
Yep.
We can see now just
now two containers
have been uploaded,
leeroy-app and leeroy-web.
So for my next step, I
want to actually now set up
my Cloud Deploy pipeline.
My containers are
built. They are ready.
So let's take a look at
what that looks like.
Within my repo, you can
see I have a declarative
manifest for my pipeline.
And it looks just like
this, and it's very simple.
I give it a name, which
I've called it "web-app"
with a description.
And then it really just
defines three stages--
test, staging, and prod.
The order in which
these are defined in
are basically the
directional flow
that the pipeline
will promote through.
So let me go into
my Cloud Shell,
and I'm going to apply that
manifest to Cloud Deploy.
All right.
You can see it's
now been applied.
I can go check out my Cloud
Deploy user interface.
I'm going to do a refresh here.
All right.
Now, we have a web pipeline,
and it's-- as we mentioned,
it's planning to promote
from test to staging to prod.
Those are actually resources as
well that need to be created.
And you can see I have those
defined declaratively as well.
I have a target-test,
target-staging,
and target-prod.
I've defined those in
separate manifests.
So I'm going to run
those, and now that
will create each of these
targets in Cloud Deploy one
at a time.
All of these could have been
added to a single manifest.
I just opted not to.
All right.
So I've created the test
target, the staging target,
and the production target.
At this point, I could
do one of two things.
The first step I'll take
is just to manually create
a release in Cloud Deploy.
So I'm going to go ahead and
create our first release.
And we're going to
call it "web-app-001."
And you can see now that
we've created the release,
and it started a rollout
to the first stage
in our pipeline,
which we call test.
If I take a look at
that, you can see
the rollout has been queued.
It's starting.
And this is what the user
interface looks like.
We show that there's a
test, a staging, and a prod.
Rollout is queued.
If you notice here,
between staging and prod,
it says "0 pending."
And what that's referring
to is zero approvals.
And it knows that because if
we take a look at our prod
manifest, we configured
it to require approval.
So we'll talk about
approvals in a little bit.
But effectively,
Cloud Deploy is aware,
and it's expecting an approval
before it allows that promotion
to that final target.
While this pipeline is
queued, we're going to go in,
and I'll show you
as well that I've
created a Cloud Build trigger
that will automatically
look for changes.
And this is-- for those that
are familiar with Cloud Build,
this is looking at my Git repo.
And any time a change happens
to that repo, a commit is made.
It's going to build
a new container,
upload it to Artifact Registry.
And then you can see
here, the second step
is it's going to then
create a new release.
So we can test that out.
I will go into my
Visual Studio code.
I have a sample app here.
Let's just call it
"Cloud Next 2021."
We're going to update the
comment here, apply the change,
"Updated comment."
We can see that
trigger is running now.
And what that trigger
is going to do,
it's going to update the
containers in the Artifact
Registry.
And then when
complete, it's going
to kick off a brand-new
release in Cloud Deploy.
OK.
Our trigger has
successfully run,
which should mean that a Cloud
Deploy release has been kicked
off, and we see that it has.
The test has been
deployed, and now
let's say we want
to do a promotion.
So we're going to go ahead
using the user interface
and force the promotion to--
kick off a promotion
to the staging target.
OK.
Our promotion to
staging was successful.
So now we really
have just one step
left-- that's to
promote to production.
But if you recall,
production also
does require a manual approval.
So we're going to kick
off the promotion.
And you can see now we
have one pending review.
I'll click the Review option.
I'm going to go in there,
and I can see that, oh, look,
I have a rollout that
does need an approval.
I do have the
appropriate permissions,
so I can go in there
and review that.
At this point, I'm
ready to approve it.
I know what changed.
I can see the differences.
And so I'm going to approve.
I'm going to go
back to my pipeline.
Our promotion to
prod was successful.
And you can see now
we have successfully
promoted an automated release
through test, staging,
and production.
This release was built
off of the GitHub
trigger using Cloud Build.
And this really showcases
the end-to-end CI/CD pipeline
using both Cloud Build
and Cloud Deploy.
To learn more about
Google Cloud Deploy,
visit us at
cloud.google.com/deploy.
Now back to you, Sander.
SANDER BOGDAN: I'd like
to thank you, Bryan,
for presenting this
talk with me today,
as well as all of you for
attending Google Cloud Next
2021.